so
i know you're 20 21 21 21.
uh so so asking you for advice is uh
is a little bit funny but uh but at the
same time not
because you've created a social network
you've created a startup from nothing as
we talked about earlier like without
knowing how to program you've programmed
i mean you've taken this whole journey
that a lot of people i think would be
really inspired by
so given that uh and given the fact that
20 years from now you probably laugh at
the advice you're going to give now
absolutely i hope so if i don't laugh at
the advice i give now
something went desperately wrong right
yeah
so do you have advice for people uh that
want to follow in your
footsteps and create a startup whether
it's in
a software app domain or whether it's
anything else
so i'll speak specifically about social
media apps
yes um try to keep it as narrow as
possible so i can laugh as little as
possible when i'm 41
and what i would say is that
if you're like a 21 22 year old who's
looking at me and being like
i want to do something like this um what
i would say is you probably know better
than just about anyone and if you have a
feeling
in yourself that this is something that
i have to do
and this is something i could imagine
myself doing for the next 10 years
because if you're successful you are
going to have to do it for the next 10
years
and through the ups and the downs
through the amazing interviews with lex
and through the
not so amazing articles you might have
with other people right
um and you're gonna have to ride those
highs and lows and you have to believe
in what you're doing but if you have
that feeling what i would say is
listen to as few people as possible
because
people are experts in domains but when
it comes to like
what's hot and what's what what makes
sense in a social context
you are the authority as a young person
who's going through these things and
living in
in your sort of milieu and
i mean i've talked to at this point you
know
so many experts experts so many
investors vcs um
so you'd be amazed at the advice i've
gotten advice i've gotten
so there's like a minefield of bad
advice that's the hardest part i think
for young people and it's the thing when
people like i help
i help yellies all the time who ask like
i never turned down
when a founder asked me to have a
conversation i never turn it down
i'm always there for them um and the
number one thing i worry about is that
at yale we're
taught implicitly and explicitly
that you listen to the adult in the room
you listen to the person with the
highest
you know pay grade and
it's devastating because that's how
innovation dies and
you know yeah it's intimidating to like
you talk to vc who probably
makes it worth a billion dollars a
billion dollars
and they're going to tell you you know
all the
all the successful startups they helped
fund or even just a successful business
owner
is going to tell you some advice and
it's hard psychologically to think that
they might be wrong
yeah but you're saying that's the only
way you succeed is the only way you can
succeed because if they knew what they
were doing they would have built it
themselves
um and what's especially hard is people
go oh of course
you know i'll listen to people's i'll
listen to their advice but i'll know why
it's wrong
yeah and then i'll and i'll do my own
thing and that sounds great abstract
but sometimes you can't always even put
your finger on why they're wrong yeah
and i think to have the conviction to
say
you're wrong and i can't tell you why
but i still think i'm right
it's a rare thing especially at like
it's very counterintuitive and you might
even say it's
hubris or yeah arrogant but i think it's
necessary because a lot of these things
are
they're not things that you can really
put into words until
you see them in action like a lot of
them are kind of happy accidents
yeah it's been it's been tough for me
like as a as a person
who um like i'm very empathetic so i
when people tell me stuff i kind of
want to understand them and it's been a
painful process especially people close
to me
basically everything i've done
especially in the recent few years
a lot of people close to me said not to
do yeah
and uh like my parents too that's been a
hard one
it's is to basically acknowledge to
myself
that you don't know like
you you don't that everything you're
going to
say by way of advice for me is not going
to be helpful
like i love my parents very much but
like
they're just like they don't get it
and and as you put it beautifully it's
very difficult to put your finger on
exactly
why because uh a lot of advice
sounds reasonable that's the worst kind
yeah
yeah uh if it if it sounds really good
that just means it's an ear worm like
that's like a song that you hear on the
radio and then you're like
you're humming it in the car and it's
like it's the same thing
the more the better it sounds the more
skeptical
yeah reason is a is a bad drug
like should be very careful because like
you know the things that seem impossible
every every major innovation every major
business
seems impossible at birth but even not
just the impossible things
i think you know you look at like love
for example
it's very easy to give advice
to sort of point out all the ways you
can go wrong or marriage
all the divorces that people go through
all the pain of years
that you go through the divorce like the
system of marriage
the marriage industrial complex all the
money that's wasted all those kinds of
things
but that advice is useless when you're
in love i guess
the point uh the point is to just
pat the person in the back and say go
get them kid like what is it the good
will hunting
and went to see about a girl oh yeah
that's a good movie i love that movie
but
yeah that that's uh that took me a long
time
to figure out i'm still trying to fight
through it but especially when you're
young that's hard but uh
nothing in life is uh worth
accomplishing is easy so
but i think it's really interesting you
make that connection between like
startup advice
and like your parents because it's the
exact same sort of mechanism
where when you're young your parents are
usually like right
yeah right and the experts are usually
right and you know if you listen to them
and you you
you follow their orders you're gonna go
to a school like yale yeah
and at a certain point stops making
sense and i've
i've seen my friends at yale go down
paths because they just
continued listening to their parents
that i know
in their heart of hearts is not the
right path for them
yeah you know what that's how i see like
the education system
the whole point is to guide you
to a certain point in your life
and everybody's point is different and
your task is to at that point
to have a personal revolution and create
your own path but no one tells you that
nobody tells you that because they're
they want you to keep following the same
path as they
they're leading you towards like they're
not going to say your whole job
is to eventually rebel yeah that's how
revolut that's how rebellion works
you're not supposed to be told
but that is the task they can take you
just like you said
and depending who you are they can take
you really far
but at a certain point you have to rebel
that could be getting you know phd
that could be in your undergrad that
could be high schools yeah it could be
any point
one thing that i think played a pretty
pivotal role and i've never really
mentioned this
um he might not even know the person
about to tell you about
um in sort of me actually going out and
making librex was that
i was taking this graduate level math
class um
into my sophomore year um and i met this
uh
i met this phd student who is also in it
and had considerable citations and also
startup experience and i think he
actually ended up being the cto of a
unicorn
later on um i've sort of lost touch with
him but we're still facebook friends
as it is in the 21st century right um
so and i was in a class and i was
telling him i really want to i really
want to make this thing but
i have no technical background um and
he this guy's a computer genius he
worked under dan spielman
a ael so yeah he's a good guy right and
we were doing some math together um we
were doing something on discrepancy
uh for those who really care about math
so combinatorics
um and uh he just turns to me he's like
i think you could do it like what do you
mean you think i could do he's like
i think you could do it yeah and i was
like really
but i respected this guy so much um his
name was young duck
um shout out to young duck i respected
this guy so much that i was like
if young duck says i can do it and young
doug is legit genius
and he knows and he knows me because we
were in two classes together and we
spent a lot of time together
if he thinks i can do it then who am i
to say i can't do it
yeah you know that's a lesson for
mentorship
is like by the way he has no idea
probably
well he might not even remember that
interaction which is funny but the the
point is
that when a crazy young kid comes up to
you
with a crazy dream uh you know
every once in a while you should just
pet them in the back and say
i believe in you like you can do it if
they look up to you
that means your words have power and if
you say
no no come on be like reasonable like
you know uh finish your schoolwork kind
of thing
like that's that's unreasonable to take
that leap now just finish your education
blah blah blah whatever
whatever the reasonable advice is every
once in a while
maybe often as a mentor you should say
you know
go see about a girl in california or
whatever the equivalent
that was my moment that was my goodwill
hunting this is your goodwill hunting
moment
oh man i miss robin williams i was a
special guy
you